EVEN AS VLADIMIRUTIN INCREASES
HIS PROPAGANDA CAMPAIGN.
JOHN AVALON WITH THE REALITY
CHECK.
>> VLADIMIR PUTIN'S BLOODY
INVASION OF UKRAINE IS NOW IN
ITS FIFTH MONTH AND HE'S BETTING
THAT SOONER OR LATER YOU WILL
STOP PAYING ATTENTION.
YES, I KNOW, THERE'S A LOT GOING
ON FROM INFLATION TO MASS
SHOOTINGS TO THE OVERTURNING OF
ROE TO AN ESCALATING
INVESTIGATION INTO AN
EX-PRESIDENT'S ATTEMPTED COUP,
BUT WE CANNOT LOOK AWAY FROM
MASS MURDER IN OUR TIME.
IN THE LAST FEW WEEKS WE HAVE
SEEN RUSSIA INCREASE ITS
TARGETING OF CIVILIANS, FIRING
ROCKETS AT A MALL AND MORE
APARTMENT BLOCKS, ALL WHILE
TRYING TO SEAL OFF THE CITY IN
SOUTHEASTERN UKRAINE.
AT THE SAME TIME UKRAINIAN
FORCES ARE PUTTING UP A DAVID
VERSUS GOLIATH FIGHT KILLING AT
LEAST TEN RUSSIAN GENERALS AS OF
MAY.
BEYOND THE BATTLEFIELD AND ITS
FUNDAMENTAL CHALLENGE TO HUMAN
RIGHTS AND THE RULE OF LAW THE
DOWNSTREAM EFFECTS OF THIS
INVASION ARE CREATING FOOD
SHORTAGES AROUND THE WORLD,
PRESSURING FOOD PRICES AND
RAISING THE SPECTRE OF NUCLEAR
WAR.
THE FACTS ARE THERE FOR ALL TO
SEE BUT NOT INSIDE RUSSIA BUT OF
COURSE AUTHORITARIANS ALWAYS
DECLARE WAR ON THE TRUTH AS
WELL.
THEY WIELD DISINFORMATION AS A
WEAPON.
A CYNICAL STRATEGY SOME CALLED
THE FIRE HOSE OF FALSEHOOD
DESIGNED NOT TO CONVINCE BUT TO
CONFUSE.
ONE TACTIC ASK TO FLIP THE
SCRIPT USING DENIAL, DEFLECTION
AND PROJECTION TO BLATANTLY LIE
AND ACCUSE YOUR OPPONENTS OF
WHAT YOU'VE BEEN CREDIBLY
ACCUSED OF.
LIKE WHEN VLADIMIR PUTIN GAVE A
RECENT SPEECH AT AN
INTERNATIONAL LAW CONFERENCE,
AND, NO, THAT'S NOT THE PUNCH
LINE AND HE SAID, GET THIS,
THERE CAN BE NO OTHER DEFINITION
FOR THE KYIV REGIME'S ACTIONS
THAN A CRIME AGAINST HUMANITY.
NOW, OF COURSE, IT'S RUSSIA
THAT'S BEING ACTIVELY
INVESTIGATED FOR WAR CRIMES IN
UKRAINE BUT THE GOAL IS TO BLUR
DISTINCTIONS.
SOME BLIND FOLLOWERS WILL EVEN
ACTUALLY BELIEVE IT.
THAT'S NOT THE ONLY TRIBUTARY TO
THIS FIRE HOSE OF FALSEHOOD
STRATEGY.
HERE IS ANOTHER TECHNIQUE, IT'S
THE I'M OFFENDED DEFENSE.
NOW, THIS WAS ON DISPLAY WHEN
THE CHEM LIN DEMANDED TO SEE THE
UK AMBASSADOR TO SCOLD HER FOR
OFFENSIVE RHETORIC ABOUT PUTIN.
IT WAS NOT FIT FOR POLITE
SOCIETY THEY SAID, INCLUDING
WHAT THEY CALLED DELIBERATELY
FALSE INFORMATION IN PARTICULAR
ABOUT ALLEGED RUSSIAN THREATS TO
USE NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
NOW, THERE'S NOTHING ALLEGED
ABOUT THESE NUCLEAR THREATS,
THEY'VE BEEN LEVELED REPEATEDLY
BY THE KREMLIN DURING ITS
INVASION, BUT OF COURSE THIS IS
CLASSIC BULLY PLAYING THE VICTIM
STUFF, PRETENDING THAT TELLING
THE TRUTH IS OFFENSIVE IN AN
ATTEMPT TO QUIET CRITICISM.
TALK ABOUT PUTTING FEELINGS OVER
FACTS.
IT'S WORTH REMEMBERING THERE IS
NO RIGHT NOT TO BE OFFENDED AND
IF THE TRUTH HURTS, WELL, SO BE
IT.
LOOK, COMPARED TO THE BLOODY
HUMAN COST THESE MAY SEEM LIKE
SMALL SINZ BUT PUTIN'S WAR ON
TRUTH IS THE BACKGROUND MUSIC TO
HIS ACTUAL WAR ON THE PEOPLE OF
UKRAINE BECAUSE AUTHORITARIANS
WANT TO NUMB PEOPLE, THEY WANT
APATHY TO AID THEIR POWER GRABS
AND BRAZEN LIES ARE A CORE PART
OF THE PLAYBOOK.
THAT'S WHY WE NEED TO CONFRONT